Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Marco Caresia
Sono qui per raccontarvi
la storia di questa maglietta:
una maglietta, diciamo,
abbastanza innocente alla vista,
la storia di una t-shirt.
Potrebbe essere la storia di un
capo d'abbigliamento qualsiasi
che noi compriamo, casualmente,
quasi ogni giorno.
Ma noi abbiamo nel nostro portafoglio
uno strumento molto, molto
potente che sono i nostri soldi,
e vi dimostrerò come scegliere
come spendere i nostri soldi
può veramente creare il
mondo che noi desideriamo.
Quindi parliamo di questa t-shirt:
l'ho presa rossa chiaramente
in onore dei TedTalk.
La prima cosa che dobbiamo
chiederci è: di cosa è fatta?
È fatta di cotone.
E quindi pensiamo di comprare
una materia naturale,
una cosa bella, che traspira, soffice,
e quindi stiamo già facendo
una scelta giusta per noi
e forse per l'ambiente.
Ma ci dobbiamo chiedere intanto:
da dove viene questo cotone?
Il cotone viene cresciuto
nel Sud del mondo,
particolarmente, diciamo,
nel Sud-Est asiatico,
in India, in Sudamerica e in Africa;
e cosa succede in questi posti?
Le persone che coltivano e che
si curano delle piante di cotone
sono spesso poco protette,
come vediamo questi poverini
che si stanno dando il pesticida
uno contro l'altro.
Non sono per niente equipaggiati,
per poter fare questo lavoro.
Quindi non solo danno un sacco
di pesticidi a queste piante-
pensate che il 25% di tutti i pesticidi
utilizzati in agricoltura in un anno
viene utilizzato per la coltivazione
del cotone, quindi tantissimo;
ma non solo, questi pesticidi,
oltre a fare malissimo alle
persone che coltivano il cotone,
rimangono nelle fibre del cotone
e quindi questa maglietta,
credeteci o no, è ancora
piena di questi pesticidi.
E poi, come è stato illustrato
molto eloquentemente prima di me,
questi pesticidi uccidono le api
e questo sappiamo
che è una cosa devastante.
E vi dirò di più:
ho letto non più di due settimane fa,
sul Venerdì di Repubblica,
che esiste un problema ancora più
grosso, legato sempre alle api.
In India ad esempio viene venduto
questo cotone transgenico,
cotone Bt, della Monsanto, e questo
cotone ha un piccolo dettaglio:
deve essere impollinato a mano.
Quindi, cosa succede?
Vengono prese, vengono vendute
da famiglie poverissime,
ad esempio nell'Uttar Pradesh, delle
bambine che hanno tra i 9 e gli 11 anni,
vengono chiaramente tolte
dalla famiglia, tolte dalla scuola
e portate, tenute in uno
stato di semischiavitù,
per fare questo lavoro allucinante
che è impollinare le piante a mano.
Devono svegliarsi prestissimo la mattina
perché il fiore maschio si dischiude
prima delle cinque e mezzo di mattina,
quindi questa questione delle api
porta anche alla schiavitù.
E poi questa bella maglietta rossa
chiaramente è stata tinta.
Guardate che fine fa questa tintura:
finisce nei corsi d'acqua, quando
non ci sono i filtri adeguati,
cosa che accade purtroppo
spessissimo nei posti
dove vengono fatte le nostre magliette.
Non ci sono i filtri, le acque reflue
di queste aziende non vengono pulite,
finiscono nei corsi d'acqua
e poi finiscono in mare,
e questo cosa vuol dire?
Che tutta la vita ittica,
tutti gli animali, tutte le piante
dei fiumi e del mare
vengono inquinati; ma non
solo vengono inquinati,
ci sono delle normative,
europee e anche americane,
che richiedono specificamente
che i capi d'abbigliamento
che vengono venduti nei nostri negozi
siano fatti con dei coloranti privi
di metalli pesanti, quindi azo-free.
Greenpeace, che non si fida tanto,
ha mandato i propri volontari,
senza dire che erano di Greenpeace,
ad acquistare dei capi d'abbigliamento
dai soliti sospetti, quindi
H&M, Zara, Benetton
ma anche un pochino
più in alto, dagli stilisti,
da Dolce e Gabbana, e da altri.
Hanno preso i capi, li hanno acquistati,
li hanno portati in laboratorio,
li hanno fatti analizzare e hanno
scoperto che questi capi d'abbigliamento
- tutti, non ce n'era uno a regola -
erano pieni di questi metalli pesanti
e quindi hanno lanciato questo allarme,
hanno lanciato la Detox Campaign
dicendo: non solo questi coloranti
orribili inquinano l'acqua,
fanno male a chi proprio tinge i capi,
ma anche alle persone normali
che si mettono queste magliette,
danno allergia alla pelle
e poi anche tante altre cose
che si stanno studiando, ma hanno un
effetto devastante anche sul nostro Dna.
E poi, chi fa queste magliette?
Quindi le maestranze tessili
che cuciono la maglietta,
quando noi siamo tutti contenti
perché questa maglietta ci è solo costata,
qui dice, 14 dollari, o 14 euro,
abbiamo fatto un affarone:
la persona che ha cucito questa maglietta
ha solo guadagnato 12 centesimi.
12 centesimi non ti fanno arrivare
molto lontano nella sopravvivenza,
e qui parlo di un'altra cosa, parlo
di quello che è il living wage,
quindi la paga di sopravvivenza,
tra virgolette.
Cosa vuol dire "paga di sopravvivenza"?
Per avere una vita decente, una persona
deve poter comprare da mangiare,
deve poter pagare l'affitto,
deve poter avere cure mediche,
deve dare educazione ai propri figli,
deve comprarsi da vestire,
deve poter avere il trasporto per andare
a lavorare o per andare in giro
e magari riuscire a mettere
anche qualche soldino da parte.
E si dice che una living wage
è un diritto di ogni essere umano.
Ma cosa succede nel mondo?
Non è esattamente così.
Guardate ad esempio
cosa succede in Bangladesh:
la Living Wage mensile sarebbe
di 259 euro per riuscire a pagare
in maniera decente tutte queste cose.
Cosa percepisce un lavoratore tessile?
28 euro e 60 centesimi.
C'è una spoporzione mostruosa:
se guardate gli altri dati,
diciamo che il Bangladesh
è quello più eclatante,
ma certo che in Cambogia non va
molto meglio, lo Sri Lanka nemmeno,
in India e anche la Cina,
di cui parliamo tanto male,
insomma, è un pochino più in alto.
Però non c'è retribuzione
equa per il lavoro
e quindi le persone sono affamate,
non riescono a vivere in maniera decente.
E poi vogliamo parlare
un attimo di sicurezza?
Avrete sentito tutti parlare
di questa tragedia
che è accaduta nel 2013,
esattamente il 24 aprile.
Infatti ogni anno c'è adesso
il Fashion Revolution Day,
che è il 24 aprile,
dove tutti siamo invitati
a metterci gli abiti
con l'etichetta all'esterno,
per dire, chi ha fatto i nostri vestiti?
Cosa è accaduto qui?
Questo era a Dacca,
era una palazzina fatiscente
dove le operaie e gli operai
erano chiusi dentro a chiave.
Cosa vuol dire?
Che c'erano le inferriate sulle finestre
e poi le porte, il gate, era chiuso
con una catena e il lucchetto
perché la guardia
ogni tanto va a mangiare,
va a prendersi il caffè
e chiude dentro i lavoratori.
Sono state confermate,
queste cose, da filmati della BBC
e anche in Italia dalla nostra Gabanelli.
Comunque, è vero.
Questa palazzina, in particolare,
aveva già delle crepe,
era già stata definita
non sicurissima, è crollata
e si è portata con sè 1121 persone
che facevano i nostri abiti a poco prezzo.
Quindi possiamo dire che questa
maglietta è fatta al 60% di cotone,
al 20% di sudore e al 20% di sangue.
Questo porta chiaramente
a persone molto, molto arrabbiate,
e quindi non abbiamo bisogno
di altro Social Unrest,
quindi di dimostrazioni,
di persone che dicono:
basta, non se ne può più, non ce
la facciamo più ad andare avanti così.
E sta succedendo
proprio in tutto il mondo.
E poi c'è lo sfruttamento dei bambini:
noi sappiamo che in tanti di questi
Paesi le famiglie hanno bisogno
che i bambini lavorino, però
se gli adulti non sono tutelati,
immaginatevi i bambini.
Infatti in Bolivia hanno fatto
ultimamente un sindacato
per aiutare a tutelare i diritti
dei bambini-lavoratori.
E poi cosa succede?
che ne compriamo talmente tante,
di queste cosine a poco prezzo,
che poi sono fatte un po' così così,
poi ci annoiamo dopo poco tempo
che le abbiamo messe
e quindi le buttiamo
e creiamo la spazzatura tessile
che sta intasando le discariche
di tutto il mondo.
Allora, io non sono qua per fare
l'uccellaccio del malaugurio
e neanche per dirvi cose
che probabilmente avete già sentito
o di cui avete già letto, ma per dirvi
che c'è un'alternativa
e che voi avete, come
dicevo prima, in tasca
la chiave per questa alternativa:
il Fair Trade, il mercato
equo e sostenibile.
Io ho avuto la grande fortuna,
una decina d'anni fa,
dopo aver passato una vita
e una carriera, facendo la moda,
quella "delle sfilate",
convenzionale, mi sono trovata
a discutere la lunghezza
di una gonna per due ore
e mi sono detta, non ce la posso più fare,
io devo fare qualcosa che
corrisponda a quello in cui credo,
io devo fare qualcosa per cui il mio
lavoro possa dare un contributo
a migliorare questo pianeta, a
migliorare le condizioni delle persone
e anche l'ambiente, ed ecco
che ho incontrato il Fair Trade.
Che cosa è il Fair Trade?
È un'associazione mondiale (WFTO)
che ha una serie di regole.
Ve ne cito alcune:
trasparenza e affidabilità;
pagamento di un prezzo equo, quindi
quello che dicevamo il Living Wage;
assenza completa di lavoro
minorile; rispetto dell'ambiente
- quindi sono delle regole che
ci sembrano tanto scontate,
ma che in realtà scontate non sono,
perché, come abbiamo
visto, in questi paesi
lo sfruttamento e le condizioni orribili
della vita di questi lavoratori
sono all'ordine del giorno.
Quindi, il Fair Trade cosa fa?
Certifica alcune situazioni lavorative
che garantiscono
questi diritti ai lavoratori
e garantiscono anche che, ad esempio,
le acque siano filtrate prima
di essere fatte uscire nell'ambiente.
Ecco, qui sono io con alcune
delle mie artigiane,
qui siamo in Ecuador,
in un posto quasi a 4000 metri
che si chiama Salinas ed è un esempio
di economia sociale
di grandissimo successo.
È un piccolo paese dove
un Padre Salesiano di Venezia
è andato quasi 40 anni
fa, lì è rimasto
e ha creato un'economia equa e sostenibile
dove per esempio, queste donne
fanno la maglieria per me,
per me in realtà come direttore creativo
della linea moda Auteurs du Monde,
che vuol dire gli Autori del mondo,
che sono appunto i nostri artigiani,
che è prodotta da Altromercato.
Noi lavoriamo con tutte queste realtà
dove appunto è pagato il prezzo equo,
alle persone viene data
una assicurazione medica,
vengono curate, lavorano
in posti di lavoro sani.
Questi sono alcuni dei capi che faccio,
questo è un cardigan di cotone
fatto da una cooperativa che è
a Katmandu in Nepal, si chiama KTS,
Kumbeshwar Technical School,
ed io li amo particolarmente perché
sono un esempio di imprenditoria sociale.
Significa che fanno sì imprenditoria,
però riversano parte
dei loro profitti nella comunità
e quindi loro hanno un sistema educativo
che offrono ai giovani bambini,
ai bambini dai 3 agli 11 anni,
bambini di strada, che non avrebbero
la possibilità di studiare,
ma che attraverso questa iniziativa
di KTS vanno a scuola.
Quindi secondo me, in questa cosa
dell'imprenditoria sociale
c'è forse la formula
per salvare questo pazzo mondo
che sta andando a quel paese:
fare imprenditoria, pagare il giusto,
occuparsi dei propri lavoratori,
ma riversare parte
dei profitti nella comunità,
rendendo la comunità
un posto migliore per tutti.
Poi si può scegliere il cotone bio,
che non ha bisogno di pesticidi,
che usa la lotta integrata:
ad esempio, io sono stata a visitare
un luogo meraviglioso in Egitto
che si chiama Sekkem,
dove viene utilizzata
l'agricoltura biodinamica
che, ad esempio,
per la lotta ai pesticidi,
utilizzano dei coni di carta gialli
all'interno dei quali
viene spalmata questa resina
molto appiccicosa e molto profumata
e quindi gli insetti
volano dentro questi coni,
attratti un po' dal colore,
un po' dal profumo,
e lì, ahimè, rimangono;
però in questo modo
la terra rimane fertile,
si possono ruotare le coltivazioni,
non inaridiscono la terra
e il cotone è un cotone biologico,
anzi biodinamico in questo caso,
che non ha tutte quelle
caratteristiche orribili viste prima.
E poi possiamo tingere il cotone,
o le fibre in generale, con le piante:
i fili degli arazzi che
vediamo nei nostri musei,
in queste ville meravigliose
sul Lago di Como,
sono stati tinti centinaia di anni fa,
eppure sono ancora vibranti e bellissimi,
e quindi c'è ancora
la possibilità di farlo.
Questo è un signore
con cui lavoro in Etiopia,
in una cooperativa che si chiama Sabahar,
dove tingono tutto con le
piante, coi colori naturali.
E se non ci non ci sono colori
naturali, ci sono colori azofree,
quindi sono colori chimici che però
non hanno questi metalli pesanti,
quindi non inquinano i corsi d'acqua
e non fanno male a chi tinge
i capi, né a chi poi li indossa.
Questi poi, di nuovo, sono alcuni capi
che ho disegnato
per la primavera-estate 2014,
quindi la mia sfida è quella
di fare una moda che sia bella,
che sia interessante, che una
abbia voglia di mettersi,
ma che allo stesso tempo
sia giusta, sia equa e sia solidale.
Questi sono due capi fatti in India.
E poi questo mi ha dato
la fortuna e il privilegio
di farmi un nome in questo campo:
sono un punto di riferimento
per tutto quello
che sono le produzioni etiche
e sostenibili in Italia e nel mondo,
e quindi ci sono dei marchi importanti,
come Moschino ad esempio,
che sono venuti da me
per alzare il loro livello
di CSR, Corporate Social Responsibility,
responsabilità sociale d'azienda,
e abbiamo fatto una bellissima produzione
di capi in uncinetto in Kenya,
con queste suore che si
chiamano le Crochet Sisters.
Poi anche Pinko è venuto da me per fare
una serie di borse, molto belle,
e gli ho proposto di farle in Etiopia.
Ho preso ispirazione da una popolazione,
da un paio di popolazioni della valle
dell'Omo che fanno body-painting
e da lì ho preso l'idea
per fare queste grafiche.
Le borse sono state prodotte
ad Addis Abeba, in una piccola fabbrica,
e alla fine sono state
prodotte 45.000 borse.
Quindi un impatto meraviglioso, su tutta
quella zona, di lavoro per tutti.
Io so che in questa sala, a Como,
siedono tanti industriali illlustri,
ne ho conosciuti alcuni ieri sera
e, se non fosse per altro,
per non fare i buonisti, quelli
che salvano il mondo,
c'è una popolazione in crescita
che sono i Millennials,
i ragazzi nati tra gli
Anni Ottanta e i Duemila.
Saranno il 46% della forza lavorativa
dell'America, in dieci anni.
Chi sono e cosa vogliono i Millennials?
I Millennials vogliono qualità
di vita e premiano le aziende
che hanno un alto profilo
di responsabilità sociale,
quindi vita verso lavoro:
vogliono qualità di vita,
premiano le aziende, si informano,
sono sempre su Internet
e sanno chi fa cosa.
E quindi, e questo è il messaggio
principale del mio intervento,
ogni volta che noi
spendiamo i nostri soldi
facciamo un voto per il tipo
di mondo che vogliamo,
quindi noi abbiamo in tasca la soluzione
e dobbiamo esserne consapevoli
in ogni nostro acquisto.
E poi, come dice la felpa che ho indosso,
che ho fatto per un progetto di Oxfam,
poi venduta da Coin,
It always seems impossible
until it's done,
è una frase di Nelson Mandela che dice:
sembra sempre impossibile,
finché non è fatto.
Grazie.
(Applausi)